[Music]
Hey y'all. How are you doing? How's the
day? I'm pretty excited to be here. Um,
I was here last year and then we were at
the summit, the agent summit not that
long ago. I've definitely seen some
familiar faces in all of those places.
So, thank you for coming to our
conversation today. Um, my name is
Allison Cosette. I am with the developer
relations team. You will likely
recognize this face from all of the
graph rag um videos on deep learning,
chilling with Andrew Ang like, you know,
all the guys. Yeah. Yeah. It's just it's
just how you roll. Um, so what I'm going
to be talking to you about today, so was
anybody in the Neo4j workshop this
morning with Zach? Oh, this is great. I
love it. It's like Neo4j did day here.
Um,
so yeah, we're going to do a few things.
So that's good. Um, you may have Well,
no, I'm going to just go like you didn't
do that. Okay. Um, so this is our repo
that we're going to be working with
today. It has a Yes.
So, is it is it not there? Because I can
see your profile, but if I can't see
your Yeah, same. I do. Uh, you know,
that would not surprise me that I made
that mistake. One moment, please.
Let's see my settings. Yeah, it probably
I think it defaults to
I know it's in here somewhere. Change
visibility. Change to public. Sorry.
All right.
Oh, now I gota
so much security.
All right.
[Music]
Sorry about that, folks.
Yes.
Confirming access. Okay. Is that better?
Excellent. All right. Sorry about that.
Um,
so yes.
Oh, so you can actually see. Yeah, I'm
always in dark mode. Sorry. Can we do
Can we do that? I don't know. Just these
lights along here. Yeah, just the lights
in front of the video screen.
We'll work on that. Um, I love that
people are raising their hand. This
makes me very excited. Like, I love
talking to people. I love being in the
room with folks. Um, so this is good. So
I'll tell you a little bit about what
our goals are for our next, you know,
120 minutes together. What we're
focusing on, obviously a lot of you went
to the intro to graph rag this morning.
How many people have been working on rag
applications already?
Yes. Yes. Yes. Excellent. How many
people have been working on graph rag
already?
A good number. Okay. Um, so what I'm
going to be doing today is talking
specifically about how you can use graph
data science to improve what you're
working on in your um, in your
applications. The reason that we are
doing this is because one of the
beauties of having a graph is you now
get access to new ways of thinking and
understanding about the data that you
have. And so my goal today is to have
everybody feel comfortable with some of
the basics of the algorithms of graph.
And you know hopefully while you're
working through this you can see
something that's going to be of
interest. There might be something that
you want to try when you get back to
your application. Um I do this a lot and
I will say the most successful workshops
we have are when people bring their real
world scenarios to bear. So we will be
going over the code but a lot of what
we're going to be doing is talking
through the the con the concepts and
around um graph as a tool for managing
your rag and we're really just going to
be talking about graph algorithms.
Anybody here come from the data science
side of things?
Oh all right we got a few. We got a few.
Um, one of the things that I think is
really interesting about the term AI
engineer is, you know, somebody said,
"Oh, it's just engineering." Like, it's
still pipelines. I'm like, "No, it's
not. It's different, right? I came in
from the AI side." And I can tell you
that none of us, none of us look at
things the same way that we did, you
know, a few years back. It isn't the
data scientists on one side and people
putting things into production on the
other. You know, we work really closely.
And so what my hope now is like the
there's this concept that people say all
the time that you know developers are
just building the pipes and that the
data scientists are worried about the
quality of the water inside the pipe but
with AI engineers we're all worried
about the pipes and the water right so
what I really want is to give you as
much as I can about the algorithms and
about the data science and get us
rolling.
So, let me see. Where's my repo? Where's
my repo? Okay. Um, yeah. So, just clone
this repo. You can you'll have it. We'll
we're going to walk through it. It's um
it's it's really just like a
clickthrough of a number of Jupyter
notebooks. Um but really like it's
mostly about the conversation that we're
going to have today is where we're
going. So, obviously everybody here like
we always start with the basics, right?
I call them the the GPS moments. So,
let's review all the things everybody
knows first. We know that in our RAG
applications, what we're really trying
to do is we're really we're getting
better answers, right? That's what
everybody here is struggling with. Um
like some of the common things I hear
people struggle with are um am I getting
the right data? Do I have the right
chunking strategy? Um how do I handle
temporal data? How do I handle data
quality? Um what are what are some of
your biggest like rag challenges?
Anybody want to share that? What just
irks you about what you've been working
on?
Everybody's so quiet. I should have
signed up a slack channel. Yeah.
Specific couple of things. One is how to
establish the relationship between the
data. Two is the volume of data, right?
Yes.
Yeah. So, we're definitely going to talk
about we're going to talk about that
today. Um I think one of the things that
we found is that the management is um
what? Oh, sorry. Um the the comment was
um how to handle the volume of the data
was a really big one and the other
element was
understanding the relationships among
the data. So did you go to this
morning's workshop? Okay. Well you'll we
have lots of video on it so we can we
can definitely get that to you. Yes I
would add like temporal relationships.
Yes. Yeah. Temporal is a really
interesting thing. Um I don't I didn't I
don't have temporal in the slides but we
can definitely talk about temporal
because it's really important for sure.
Um one of the things that we find is you
know I I I will give you my apologies
upfront. I get super excited about
graphs. So I apologize in advance if I
am overly enthusiastic about what I do
because I love graphs and there's so
many times where something comes up and
you're like oh well if you use graph you
could address it this way. So I just
want to, you know, keep bringing these
things up and let's talk through all of
them. But what we're really looking at
is how do we give this complete and
curated response, right? What are we
using for the external data? I mean,
initially everybody dropped their stuff
into Pine Cone or WVA, you hit a vector
store. Um, is anybody now working with
multiple databases feeding into their
rag system a little bit? Yeah, still
primarily vectors. primarily vectors.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, everybody uses
vectors because they work, right? Um,
and that's the starting point, but the
thing about the vector is the vector
really is I the analogy I always say is
it's like you have a bunch of little
index cards. And so imagine if I'm the
my first day on the job and everything
there is to know about my is about what
I have to do is on an index card and I
say, "Oh, well, what do I know about
this?" And then somebody finds the index
card with this little blurb. And so like
I've just got these little things, but I
don't understand how it all puts
together, right? We don't understand
what is it connected to, right? What is
it connected to? What context do we
need? And so what I want you to start
thinking about is what are the projects
that you've already been working on?
When you're getting those answers back,
what are some of the pieces of
information that you wish your vector
had? Right? Anybody have an idea of
something they you don't have to share,
but like you've thought about like, oh,
if only it could do this, right? If only
it knew about that, I would get a much
better answer. If you haven't, then I'm
sure like the your business folks that
you're responding to have because they
always have an opinion, right? So, one
of the things about the knowledge graph
is that it's a way for us to bring our
structured data and our unstructured
data together. The other thing that it
will do is it will actually find
knowledge inside of your unstructured
documents. Right? So, one of the things
you brought up was how do we create the
relationships among these documents or
among these pieces of information? And
there's a couple of ways that happens.
One is it's really explicit, right?
There's a table of information inside
this document and you can pull that out,
right? Old school reax, everybody's
friend. or it's something that is less
explicit and more implicit and that's
where the LLMs come in finding out what
is in there. So in the this morning's
one and if you um want to hit us up we
can definitely show you how we actually
extract and build the knowledge graph.
What we're working with today is I have
a a database already set for you folks
that is a data dump that we're going to
load into your pro trials. But the thing
is this data comes from lots of
different places. So I guess most people
here are familiar with the graph. But
just in case I do like the my little GPS
moments. Let's talk about all the things
we already know. What is a graph? Right?
Basically we start with nodes. Nodes are
entities. They're your nouns. They're
your items. Some people relate them to
the tables in your, you know, relational
database. These are your table names,
right?
But the important thing is the
relationships among those entities. So a
customer and a product, a product and a
part, a you know supplier and a buyer.
It's the relationships in and among
these pieces of information that's where
our business and where our information
lives. In this case, we've got two
people. One of them owns a car, one of
them drives the car. They do know each
other. I'm not sure why person one lives
with person two, but not the other way
around. Who knows? Life is interesting,
right? Um so we have these relationships
and this tells us what is the the story
of the interaction am between and among
these
and
properties. This is where we get into
the nitty-gritty. We get into the
details. These are those extra columns
within the table, right? Our
relationships are our foreign keys. Our
properties are the columns. The entities
are the tables like roughly, right? You
know, don't quote me on it, but pretty
close, right? as from a conceptual
point. Um these properties can live on
the entities. They can also live on the
relationships, right? So we can see that
this person has been driving the car
since this date. It's a very old car
now. Um but one of the other things that
we're going to see is we see underneath
this car, we see a couple of things.
We've got uh the brand, the model, we
have a description of the car, and what
you'll see underneath is the description
embedding. So, we're all familiar with
the embeddings, right? The embedding is
a way of taking some piece of text,
putting it into, you know, many, many
dimensions, and creating a vector in
space that represents the semantics of
whatever that text is.
One of the things that's really great
about a graph is that you have
immediately that connection from the
embedding to all of the other
information. We see it in this microcosm
here of the car, the embedding of the
car. And you can pretty quickly see, oh,
if I did a vector search on, you know,
this car, right? Um, and I wanted to
know who are the people that own cars
described like X. It's a pretty quick
traversal. You're going to do a vector
search. It's going to take you to that
node, that entity, right? Similar to
your chunks that you've already been
working with. But immediately you
already have all the relationships built
in because they're already in the
database, right? We don't have to we
don't have to like create new tables and
views. Everything's already there and
it's connected. So when you go into
graph rag and you're working with your
retrievers, the beauty of the retriever
is in this ability to traverse and
traverse very quickly and get that
immediate context. Right? So these are
the basic components of what we're going
to be working with within the database.
So we're going to start at the very
beginning, right? How does this how does
this work? We start with the entity. The
first entity is the document and the
document has a chunk, right? Pretty
straightforward. It's a row in your
vector store, right? But this is the
interesting thing. You also have like
anybody here working with agents
already? MCP servers. Yeah. The other
thing that we get and what we're going
to be talking a lot about today is the
application. I call it the application
graph. Like they call it a memory graph.
For me, it's what is the actual activity
that's happening in the system? What is
what is it doing? What are the messages
going in and out? What are the context
documents that are being used? Right?
Everything that we're building is moving
quickly and it's moving at volume.
There's masses amount massive amounts of
documents and data. There's so so much
volume. How do we actually manage it?
What do we do?
This is going to be a key part of what
we talk about today, which is the actual
understanding of what's happening in the
application and how by monitoring and
looking at what's going on in the
application, you can do things like
manage your documents at scale. you can
understand what are the actual important
documents, what's influencing outcomes,
right? Um I've got some some good
stories to to share with you about what
people have been working on. Um one of
the things you mentioned is what other
elements are there. So when we look at
the entirety of the graph, we have like
the memory graph or the application.
it's connected to the chunks and then
those chunks are connected to the
domain, the products, the people,
basically all the other structured
pieces of your business or the
structured elements that you've
extracted from those unstructured
documents. So what you end up with is
you end up with a fully connected
network of your data and your system
together.
So much of the way that we have
approached development prior is you had
your data people over here and your
building people over there. We're all
together now, right? We all work
together. And the way that we have to
build is we build from that cohesive
point. We build from the data and the
application at the same time. So I'm
just going to show you what becomes
possible as you start taking this kind
of an approach. Everything that we're
looking at today is just this little bit
of the graph, right? So, we're going to
be looking at prompts and responses, and
we're going to be looking at the context
documents that they're connected to. And
then from there, we're going to say,
"Okay, let's let's figure out what where
we go now and what we can start to
understand." Anybody have any questions
so far?
All sounds really obvious, like why are
you still talking about this? Too slow,
too fast? Are we good? You're good.
Okay. All right. Good pacing. Um, if I
go too fast, because I'm from New York,
I'm a fast talker. let me know if you're
getting bored just kind of give me one
of these and be like okay like let's go.
Um so that's fine too. Uh but the best
thing that you can do is like when you
have a question just raise your hand
because everybody has the same kinds of
questions. Everybody's struggling with
things. And what I love about AI
engineer is I get to be with the people
who are doing the things that are like
you are the people that are making
everything happen right now, right? I
mean, our entire world is in like just
this incredible transformation and y'all
are the people that are building it. And
so I want to be here to support you in
this moment because it's a pretty
exciting time. So please don't be shy.
Questions, comments? Yes.
Oh, I will I will drop it in. It's not
in right now, but I will drop it in
before uh before we leave. Thanks. Yeah.
All right. Um that's a good question.
Differentiate between the previous
slide. Yeah.
Oops.
Yeah. So, they're all the same system.
They're really just sort of like
neighborhoods, right? They're kind of
neighborhoods in the system. Um the
reason that we draw it out is because
oftent times people think of them as
separate, right? So um this one doesn't
have everything, but what we see here is
we've got this has a this one has the
source. So the yellow nodes are things
that are coming from your application.
The blues came from unstructured data.
Um, we're not doing it today, but if you
had structured data that you were also
pulling in like a bringing in a table,
bringing in some of or whether it's, you
know, already structured or has been
brought out of your unstructured data,
that would be just a different color.
It's all one system. But the reason that
we do this is just so that people
conceptually understand where it's
coming from and like what does it do?
Because the big thing really is
understanding the fact that once it's
all connected, your application is
talking to all of the data and then your
structured and your unstructured are all
working together and at any time you
have access to understanding across that
system. It's like you know complex
systems and system thinking and all that
good juiciness. So they're not separate,
they're just neighborhoods. Yes. So So
um when you
you proposing that you have like one
massive graph? Yeah. I mean, don't start
with a massive graph, right? Like, let's
be honest, let's start with something
small. I mean, my first piece of advice
is always start small. Um, the other
thing to really, as always, we always
want to look at optimization. We want to
make sure that we're building for the
latency that we need. There there's
always going to be context. Yes. Can you
elaborate on that? I mentioned it this
morning as well. Yeah. start small, but
when you're trying to map, for example,
the ontology of of an organization and
be able to have an assistant have access
to that. Yeah. We've always had to go
big. How do you how do you how do you do
small break it apart or Yeah. Um well, I
mean, that's probably an ABK question.
Yeah. So, some of the complexity like
for for really big graphs, part of the
bigness of it is not just the number of
nodes and relationships you have, but
the number of labels and relationship
types that you have. And for like a
large organization, don't oversp
specify. So you start up with like kind
of generic terms, see if that works. And
if you've got too many too much volume
in the generic terms to segment, then
you get more specific. And so and the
other part about that I suppose is that
you start with not all of the data, but
like some of the data, work with it, do
some eval, figure out if it's doing what
you want to, and then refine before you
suck in everything and create the entire
database. So you kind of iterate on the
schema with a subset of the data. It's
normal data engineering I guess, right?
Yeah. Do just some of the data, start
generic and then get more specific. Yep.
Follow when you say sorry the um
when you say um big versus small, you're
talking ontology, not knowledge graph,
right? Correct. Yeah. Yeah, that's
right. So So talking about the ontology
or the schema like the how the graph is
actually laid out rather than the number
of each kinds of things, right? So
starting there iterating on that first
and then bring in all the data. Yeah.
Yeah. What are your thoughts on the
raptor indexes or representing indexes
in a tree based structure on based on
some versus knowledge graphs? What
performs better in what scenarios?
That's definitely a good uh the raptor
based indexes like if you represent
content in more hierarchical treebased
structures and then you are having
summaries and a hierarchical nodes
searching through those versus knowledge
graphs. Which scenarios plays out
better? like we should go with wrapper
indexes versus knowledge graphs or yeah
the right answer is the annoying answer
of it depends and so you should have
your eval drive the structure right so
come up with some eval what are what are
you actually trying to do what are the
questions people are going to ask and
it's the usual thing the questions
people that you're going to ask or
people are going to ask should drive the
data model here the ontology but that
also ends up meaning do you put things
into summarization over communities or
do you have the knowledge graph
representation of it that's going to be
driven by the questions
Y makes sense. Thanks. Y So
if you can find your way to that
workshop near forj, I've just pasted in
an open AI key there. You're going to
end up needing that at some point um
while we get this repo updated. And I
guess at the meantime as well, I'll just
answer any arbitrary questions you have.
Yeah, dismbiguation. There are two
channels. One is Neo4j Works of Neo4j
and the other one works Neo Forj 2025.
Yeah, it's neither of those really. It's
the graph analytics workshop. What? No,
I've done so many different workshops
lately. Like it's Yeah, I'll clean up
the repos. Sorry. The Slack channel.
Yeah. Oh, no. So, oh, you have a Slack
channel. There's a Slack channel on the
AI engineers workspace. There's two.
Okay. So, it should be the workshop
new-j one, not the workshop new forj
2025. I didn't realize there was yet
another one. Okay. All right.
All right.
Yeah. Thank you Devon for putting in the
the GitHub link. Hold on. Hold the phone
because
do this.
So one of the things that we're going to
end up exploring here and we we touched
on this a little bit this morning um
some of the motivation behind both graph
rag and then also doing graph analytics
on top of the graph. One of the aspects
I I always like to call out and it isn't
as as obvious I think until you gets
pointed out and then it's super obvious
is that part of what we're doing is for
the core data you start with
particularly with unstructured data if
you're doing chunking of course that by
using graph rag and graph analytics
you're expanding the number of
answerable questions for the same base
data set that if you would say roughly
for every chunk you've got you can
answer one question right and it's being
linear Number of chunks equals number of
questions you can answer. If you would
think for every chunk you've got, you do
the and this is the upper bounds. Take
every pair of chunks do the cartisian
product of all the chunks. Say what do
these two chunks have together have in
common or how are they different? Create
relationships or don't create
relationships in them in the upper
bounds that is now you know n squared
number of possible connections. Every
time you do that that's new information
that's possible. So now you've got an
order of magnitude more, you know,
questions that can be answered. Once
you've got everything connected, you can
then also do the community detection
stuff that they touched on this morning
and we'll get into maybe a little bit
today as well. That now that you've got
all these chunks connected, it's not
just the pair-wise connections that are
new information. It's the subsets that
are through those connections that also
can answer new bits of information. So
that if you have if I'm in the graph and
you're in the graph and you're in the
graph, you know, or you over there,
whoever, maybe Allison, that it's not
just us individually, but like how we're
related and who we know, the connections
between us and the connections across
everybody else. All that ends up being
slices of the graph that are particular
to the individual places that you
started. That ends up forming all this.
It's not the full power set of all the
subsets within the set but it's hugely
amount like if you started with like 10
chunks by just going to the pair wise
connections you end up with 100
answerable questions and once you start
doing the the sub communities so the
subset of all the sets at the upper end
it ends up being exponential. This is
the power of graphs. Yes, it's two to
the n instead of n squ right we do love
math. Thank you ABK. Um okay so we have
pushed if you have pulled you will want
to refresh this poll uh this fork. So um
what you're going to see is a few
different things. One is uh I do have a
link actually to the slides and then um
actually we're not doing docker you can
ignore that. Um but when we go down to
the bottom in connecting to Neoforj or a
DB you're going to see the link to um
you're going to see the link to console
neoforj.io.
So we're going to have everybody go
there. When you get in there, um, you're
going to create a new instance. So, let
me Oops, sorry.
Yeah, it's console.ne4j.io.
Uh, this is in the readme in the
repository. Do you not? Let me see.
Is it in the slack channel?
Which which Slack are we? Are we 2025?
Not the 2025. We're not 2025. We're old
school. We're not 2025.
We're either in the future or deep in
the past, but we are not right now. All
right. We're the other one. Um so when
you go in there, you're going to have a
couple of different options for free
tiers. One is um the aura free in the
aura free, which is smaller, doesn't
work as it doesn't have as much of the
optimization as the pro trial. So we're
going to be using the pro trial today.
Um I believe it's 14 days right now on
the prot trial but you can if you want
to work on your own project later go in
and start an aura free instance as well
and um that as long as you're querying
it every so often like it'll stay open
and it will always stay free. Yes.
What's that? Is there a preference on
the cloud provider? Um no it's your
choice. Your choice. What was the
question? Oh, sorry. The question was,
"Is there a preference for cloud
provider?" And I said, "No, there is
not. The more you spread it out, the
easier it is." We move along. Um, yeah.
So, you're going to get the free trial
up and running. And so, um, what that is
going to look like when you create the
instance, you're going to see a couple
of options. You're going to go with the
Ora DB Professional. We're not taking
our credit card. We're not doing
anything. Eventually, it'll turn off.
Um, but it just is the most robust
version that we have. So, I guess it's
seven days. Seven days. So, you're just
going to try that for free and you're
going to get that up and running. Why do
we still have an ORADS button? No. Okay.
All right. Don't worry about that. Yes.
Oh, yeah. Um, onboarding. Sorry. Um,
yeah, it just passed. I mean, it's going
to ask you some questions. You can just
like it does that thing where it makes
you make the graph thing. Oh yeah.
Sorry.
Yeah. It doesn't I mean anything is
fine. Like
don't tell anybody. It's a marketing
thing. Like just pass through it. We
want to just get you enabled. Um and
then when you go through you can just
use the default. It's going to default
to four gigs. Um you know if you want to
name your instance you may. One of the
things that's going to you can
definitely turn on graph analytics and
vector optimization if you want. Um, and
then just click accept and and it'll
start up your instance and it'll take a
couple of minutes. Once that instance is
up and running, we'll get you to the
dump and we'll get that loaded in. So,
I'm just going to give everybody a
couple of minutes to work on this. If
you get stuck on this process, just
raise your hand because I got lots of my
people, my Neo4j people, wave.
Alexi, that's you, too. Wave. Yeah.
Yeah. Yes. You're being he's being
called on in class, right? Um he wasn't
asleep, so that's good. He was just
working. Um yeah, so if you get stuck on
anything, just let us know. Okay. But
what I can do while we're while y'all
are getting that up and running is I can
show you a little bit about what is
inside of our database. Um the the
console, it makes it really easy. Not
only do you have access to your
instances, you have access to graph
analytics, but um you know the basic
IDE, which is the query uh will be
connected as well. So,
got one of each. Let's see what's in the
database.
Oh, I No, that's right. I I emptied it
because I wanted you guys to be able to
like do the dump with me. Okay. Oh, no,
there it is. Okay. All right. Okay. So,
we've got the query. And in the query,
for those of you who love your cipher,
you know, we can say
return n limit 10. Um, all the cipher
that we're using today, like I've
already I've already got in the
notebooks. Um, but what the what you'll
see is when when you do a query,
querying in cipher is really all about
the pattern. So in this case, I'm just
doing a match. N you probably can't see.
I was gonna ask you now. Yeah, I'll fix
it. Hold on. I gotta make this so people
can see all the things. See all that?
No, that's not going to work. We're
gonna zoom in. Um, sorry. Yes.
Oh, okay. Okay. Um, if you already have
an account Oh, yeah. Oh, you know what
you can do? If you already have an
account, one of the things you can do is
you can log back in and if you change
your email to your email plus like
workshop before the at@ symbol, it'll
give you a fresh account.
So like if if like mine if I'm like
Allison at you know Google, if I do
Allison plus workshop at Google, it'll
still be your email address. It'll still
go to you, but it will be seen as a new
account. So that's another option.
Create a new account. Yeah, just create
a new account. Okay. It'll make your
life easy.
Has anybody been able to get their
theirs up and running
is? No. Yeah, maybe. It's so interesting
because lately I've been noticing like
people are so interested in engaging in
conversation. There's uh less of that,
but we definitely don't want to leave
anybody behind. So, we'll let you all do
that. So, but just to understand what is
actually happening inside Neoforj when
you're working with it. Um we run these
we run these patterns, right? So it's
similar to you know SQL like the good
news is it's very userfriendly cipher um
and we live in the age of like vibe
coding and LLM so like there's plenty of
help for all of this within our
co-pilots um but depending on what you
get back in this case you can look at it
as a graph you can see the table um or
you can see you know just the raw values
but the the graph itself so um in this
case we're looking at a particular
document which is actually you know we
call call it a document. It's really the
chunk. Um I will tell you that what we
have in our what we the data that we're
working with is from a project that we
actually have live. Um and it's called
agent neo and it was built a while ago
now with uh by some of the guys who were
helping build the first rag application
on our graph data science platform um
and our knowledge share there. So this
has been in play for a while. But when
we look at the data model itself, right,
what you're going to see is what I
talked about before, right? That
application understanding. So we've got
a session. So somebody logs in to the
application, they start a conversation.
They have their first message, right?
This is the user prompt. Then that
prompt is going to get an answer, right?
There there's a message that comes back
from the assistant. And then that
assistant is going to be going out and
pulling in context documents, right? So
it's going to do your cosign similarity.
who does uklitian I don't know it's a
thing I guess um does your cosign
similarity and it's going to bring those
documents back and you're we're going to
start to see the chain of what that
conversation looks like right so this is
that application base and then these are
these are the chunks so it's really just
what we looked at in that previous view
but just to show you what it actually
looks like
so what's in this you know lots of
documents from our documentation
developer blogs support Um, we, this was
early on, our earliest chunking. We had
a 512 chunk size. Um, we used a lang
chain recursive splitter. So, it was
pretty early on. Um, let me see. Hold on
a second. I want to show you.
Where are my That's not what I want to
show you. Where did it go?
Here we go.
All right.
So once the the system actually starts
running, what you see is this is this is
actually one user having two different
conversations. This is their first
conversation. This is our second
conversation. The first question is can
you build graphs for me? And then the
next one was what is GDS? And then you
see the beginning of what that response
was. Yes, I can build for you. GDS
stands for um and so you can just to
give you an idea of how this starts to
build out. Now this might look a little
bit frightening but I'll walk you
through what we're actually looking at.
So what does it mean when we start
looking in practice? So this is the same
user right with those initial two
conversations. Um what does graph data
science uh yeah what is GDS? This is
also what is GDS and then can you build
graphs for me? And what we're looking at
here is these are the conversations and
these are the context documents that are
being brought in. And what's interesting
or plausible it makes sense. This person
asked the same opening question. So it
stands to reason that these same
documents are going to be used in both
of these first responses. Right? Makes
sense. Then what we find is this
person's next conversation says um how
can I have how can I learn more about
GDS? is their follow-up question, right?
And that makes sense that it's going to
now share things with can you build
because this person is then having their
next prompt which is oh no that that one
stopped after one. But what I wanted to
show you is that what we see here is
that in this middle conversation, the
conversation started out in this area of
information, right? It started out in
what is GDS? What are some of the
basics? But then the conversation went
into something similar to someone else.
And the reason that we want you to see
this is you want to be able to see how
are the conversations connecting to the
data itself because what we're going to
start to see is we're going to start to
see that it's not just about a single
row. It's not just about a vector
because the way the documents are used
and the way people travel through your
data gives you information about what
they're using. The reason that becomes
helpful is when you're trying to manage
at scale, how do I know with all these
documents? What are the ones that I
should even be looking at? What is it
that people are constantly going back
to? What are the areas of knowledge
where things are happening? And so what
we're seeing here is that these elements
right here were in both answers, right?
So you see this first question had this
first response had context and this had
context. So it was in both of those.
These are individuals. These over here
were only in this one. Some of those
were only in that one. You can imagine
like how quickly this gets very very
hairy.
Oh, where did it go? No, I guess that's
it. I didn't have the extra one. Um so
the the point is we can we can start to
understand the movement of what's
happening. Is there a question someone?
No. Okay. Anybody have any questions so
far? Ponderings?
Waiting till we get to juicy things.
Yes.
Yes. Yes. The pink ones are the chunks.
The orange is the user prompt. The tan
is the um the the rag application's
response.
So you can already see how it's starting
to connect to the system itself, right?
So let me get back on point here. We got
things. We got things things.
Okay. And sorry
how performant is that?
Yeah. So what we're going to see is we
are actually we do actually have the
chunk. Um our chunks are pretty small.
Um I the size of the of the text doesn't
really change the performance, does it?
Like as far as like once it's stored in
the property, it's really the traversal
that is where things for most chunk
sizes it's fine because most chunks are
like in the K at most. It's not
megabytes of chunk, right? If there's
megabytes then it's like okay that
becomes problematic. Yeah. I mean but it
would be that for any database I would
imagine. Yep. Yeah.
Um but what we see is is like you know
we said we had these properties. So for
this particular document, um I've run
some of these things already, but we've
got the document, we've got the text,
and we have the embedding. The embedding
is actually a property of the node
itself. And that's one of the things
that makes it really easy is that you
don't have to have a separate vector
database, right? The vector is actually
stored and then the vector index is
built on top. So once you get all those
vectors in, you can run the vector
index. And people do really interesting
things with vector indexes for sure. Um,
so this is where that's not what I want.
This is where we start.
Question.
You definitely have a question. Whether
I have an answer is the only thing
that's up for debate. So let's assume,
right? Um, I have very large say legal
documents, right, which I'm trying to do
something very similar. Yeah. And I do
these chunkings, you know. Yeah. Would I
are you saying I would store the chunks
in the
store the vectors in a vector database,
but I'll also store that in. Yeah. And
how would that be from a performance
standpoint over time? Like assuming your
system continues to grow, um, wouldn't
there be a performance impact? Um, I
don't know. Would you know what the
largest rag application is that we have
in production in clients right now? It's
a good question. I don't know. I know
that's like, you know, tens of millions,
you know, seems fine. Once you start to
get to hundreds of millions, you might
start to have to worry about like what
how to scale past that.
Yes. And does it still query across look
for similarity across all embeddings?
Yeah. I mean, so it depends. So what it
will do is it will look across whatever
the vector index is that you have and
there are people who I said they do some
really interesting things with vector
indices. So um I've seen people who like
have multiple vector indices depending
on what the use case is. So when you
when you create the vector index, you
actually just do a query and you say,
"Okay, for all of these, create an index
on all of these nodes." And so that's
one way that I definitely know people
have been doing it. So they'll have
multiple indices that already sort of
presort or prefilter what's going to be
part of what's coming back from the
vector index. So um I know one of the
ways I've seen people do it is from a
governance perspective. So there's
certain data that they want available to
everybody, certain data they don't, and
they manage that from the vector index.
Yes, please. I'll let you go for a
third. Really?
Um, the other question is if we had
documents that actually contained images
and we wanted to somewhat have a
relationship between the text and
images, how would you do it here? Does
that make sense? Yeah. I mean normally
multimodal I think most of the time they
keep the images separate and then
there's a there's an embedding of the
image on the node. That's right. Yeah.
Yeah. So you'd put the image like large
media files you would put that in an S3
bucket or something. You still wouldn't
you wouldn't put that into the database.
So you'd have a URL to the S3 bucket but
you can put the embedding into so on the
node. Yeah. Yeah. We actually have an
example of that. Yeah. I have a question
for
you have multilayer.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it's not it's I mean, it's
mostly just the way that the database is
actually built because of the way the
queries run because you're running on a
pattern. um you actually I I kind of
call it uh it's like GPS search where
it's like start here and then go find
what you need to find. Right? So I I
don't know if that's the best way to
explain that, but um when you're running
the query, it's going to be very
specific. So when you're thinking about
um like like how you're running the
vector retriever itself, are you talking
about like when you're actually doing
the retrieval from the vectors? Yeah. So
there's a whole um I don't even know how
many how many retrievers there are right
now. like eight different retrievers or
something um in the the graph rag
package. It's a Python based package. Um
so there are some if you go to actually
great place to go is graphrag.com. It's
like an open like reference point and it
talks about some of the different types
of retrievers. So you can do
pre-filtering, you can do postfiltering.
Um you can manage it based on the index
which is another like easy way to do it.
Um you know sometimes folks will have
them where they have different
hierarchies. So like when you think
about these large legal documents,
right? Um there are ways that you can
actually like create the chunks but use
the natural structure of the element as
well. So like we have an example we use
with SEC data. Every time somebody files
something with the SEC, you know,
paragraph one is always this, paragraph
7 is that, paragraph 9 is that. And so
you'll take whatever that natural
architecture is within the documents
themselves and then you can you can
leverage that as well. So, one of the
other great things about um these
entities is that you can actually have
more than one label.
Let me see.
Oh, I got to plug in.
So, one of the things that you'll see is
so for this particular this particular
one, we see that it's a message, but
it's also noted that it's the assistant.
So you have some nodes that are that
have more than one label sometimes. So
it makes it so that if you wanted to go
across all messages, but I know if I'm
trying to understand um just the prompts
from the just the assistant answers or
just the prompts, I don't need all of
those messages. So by adding on dual
labels, you can actually say, "Oh, I
just want to see these or I just want to
see those." So it it it allows you to
get some of that nuance out of that
complexity by leveraging multiple labels
on a single node. One of my favorite
tricks personally, but that's just me.
Sorry. Yeah. I have a question. Ah, hi.
So now like if you have one vector index
but don't want to actually search the
entire index, right? Yeah. So since that
like let's take this text for example or
like content for example. Uhhuh. you
want to only search the content of few
nodes
via vector embedding. Is that possible?
I mean, there's a number of ways that
you can do that. Um, you know, you
certainly could. I mean, I personally
I'm a big fan of multiple indices just
because I find them to be very
efficient. Um, that's one way to do it.
Um, there was a question earlier about
temporal issues. Um you can also use
like multiple vector indices to address
that temporal portion as well right so
you can create an index from why is this
all right it's starting up um you can
create a vector index so like
like if we wanted to like if we wanted
to have a vector index just on you know
version one nine or version 26 or
whatever you could have that particular
vector so let's just say I'm building
building a chatbot and the I know that
the customer is currently running
whatever version of something, you can
use that as the as the actual index that
you're searching for. So that's another
way that you can that you can address
those kinds of things. Did that answer
your question? So it's just like so it's
just like multiple embeddings. I mean
multiple indexes so not one index. I
mean I don't know I don't know if
engineering would agree with me but from
like a purely like practical like I got
to hack this and get it done. That's my
go-to. I mean, is there Yeah, I think
that's the right approach right now with
new forj. I I guess you're asking about
metadata filtering within the vector
index, right? Yeah. And so for us, the
vector index is just an index. It's not
a vector search, right? Um and so we
don't do metadata filtering on the
vector itself. We use the property graph
itself for doing the filtering. Right?
So you do it before you create the index
because the index is only going to go to
what's connected to it, right? Um so
it's you'll still have the index, but
then you can do predicates on top of the
nodes you found and then you filter
after that. Yeah. So, even within with
once you get that, you can certainly
filter in and around that as well. Y and
if you look at um any of our the vector
retriever materials we have like we walk
you through that. We've got we got a new
ebook coming out. It's gone to print.
It's happening um that specifically
talks about those retrievers.
All right. Multiple labels, multiple
indices, all the good things. So, let's
do this. So, for those of you who have,
let's go back to here. Um, the other
thing you're going to see on the readme
is you're going to see this Neo4j dump
file. Um, this is the actual dump file
from from our database from last year, I
think. Um, then so we're going to we're
going to give that to you. So, you can
download that file and I'll show you how
you can drop that into your
let me see. Sorry.
[Music]
All right. So when we go back to our
instances, so you should see instance
instance 01 most likely. If you go on
the right hand side of there, there are
three little dots. What you're going to
see is backup and restore. So you're
going to click on backup and restore and
you're going to take that dump file and
either browse or just drag and drop it.
and it's going to drop in um our our
version of the Neo4j agent uh agent Neo
GDS
application data I guess things um so
yeah so you just drag and drop it it
runs pretty quick it'll load pretty
quick um and then what you'll see is
when you go to query you'll see this
will start to populate the database
information will populate and it'll show
you which nodes you have which nodes and
entities you have. Um it'll bring in
some of the indices. There is we did run
some of the algorithms already. So I'm
going to show you how to run them so you
can run them on your own. Um but in the
in the interest of time we we have run
those already. So you'll see some of
that. Some of them we'll we'll do live
here. They won't be there. Is anybody
able to load? Yes.
Oh yeah. So on the readme on the readme
in the repository if you go all the way
down to the bottom where it says connect
to Neoforj or a DB there's a Neoforj
dump file that it'll take you to.
Sorry.
Yeah. And then you'll just download it
from there. What's that? Oh, sorry. So
when you're in when you go to console,
right, you should be seeing something
like this,
right? All right. And then on the right
hand side for your instance, you'll see
three little dots. We're going to click
on those dots and you're going to go to
backup and restore.
And my data is yours. I give it to you.
Just dumping it right on you. All right.
Um yeah, it's just easier. Nobody wants
to load CSVs today. We have no time for
these things. Um yeah, and then from
there you can go straight into the
query. So when you go to query, you
should see that it's populated. Is there
anybody having trouble loading the data
that wants to load the data?
It's still uploading. Okay. What's that?
I couldn't find the
if you if you did you you might have had
to repole because I I if you repull the
repo. Yeah, I had to update it because
you know I'm well intentioned but sorry.
Yes. Um when I've uh restored the dump
file. Yeah. Should I expect that it will
work in like few minutes? Yeah, it
should. Let me see what you got. Um it
keeps doing the loading. It's still
loading. So that's normal. There's like
a lat. It shouldn't be too slow. Oh,
what is Oh, you're probably having
network issues.
Wi-Fi is pretty slow. Oh, sorry. Yeah,
that's always the the challenge with
these things. Um,
yeah, Wi-Fi. See, this is why we always
have it loaded. I also have it loaded on
my desktop because that happened to me
recently. I was somewhere and I'm like,
there's no Wi-Fi at all and I have to
present. So, I also have Neo4j desktop.
So, if anybody ever, you know, you want
to go local, you want to stay on prem,
you don't want any up in your business,
you can also like stay off the cloud, go
local also an option. Um, let's see,
where are we? So, what are we going to
do here?
All right. So, I'm going to go into So,
within our notebooks, we have three
different notebooks. One is uh the get
to know your graph. And we'll start
there. I don't need this. Um, and really
it's like all this is going to do is you
you'll run it, you'll do your pip
install of all your requirements, and
then what you'll what Oh, wait. I need
to give you is the OpenAI key on here,
too? Hold on. Oh, I put it in the Slack
channel. Oh, it's in the Slack channel.
Okay. So, anybody can find it anywhere
in the conference. WhatsApp. Enjoy.
Security. So, when you when you set up
your database, they should have given
you the opportunity to download your
credentials. Yes, I've set that up. Got
it.
Um,
what is this not not
Oh, um, did you drop the So, you have to
drop I sorry I skipped a spot. You do
need to drop the those credentials that
you downloaded into your in your env
file. So you did that. This is your env.
Okay. And then
just pasted it. Yeah, it should be.
Let me see.
Yeah, there it's right here. Yeah,
you've got that. Um, what is it
actually? What's the actual error? Is it
just Wi-Fi?
What does it say down here? Schema
bolting.
Yeah. Um, I was just Yeah, the URI
should be in your credentials. Exactly.
I was just I was just thinking I just
It should be It should be I would take a
peek at it. ABK, can you take a look and
see what's happening here?
All right. So
um yeah, so again the the API key is
there. We're not using it actually that
much today. Um but one of the things
that we have obviously is we need to
have Oh god, you can't see anything.
This thing can't see anything. Oh
goodness. Well, that's overwhelming.
That's more reasonable. Okay, is that
good? You guys can see we're good. Okay.
Um yeah, so the basics obviously we're
importing OS. We're bringing in our our
environment variables. Um you see the
Python driver, right? This is our
classic Python driver. And then what I
like to do is I like to just do a run
query um uh function just because it
just makes it easier. Like I I just like
it. Um you don't have to do it this way.
You could just do drivers session, but
um that's just how I like to do it. And
then when you run this, it'll see that
yes, you are actually connected. Let's
see. Maybe I should actually run
everything.
Now we're connected. Okay. Um the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
just going to take a look at what is
actually in the database. So in this um
Apoch actually stands for awesome
procedures on cipher which I just think
is hilarious. I think there's a double
meeting on Apoch too but we'll have to
ask um isn't there an a another Apoch
meaning something? I don't know. matrix.
Yeah, some some matrixy thing. Um, but
what this is going to show you is we
start out with 17,000 nodes, right? We
have 774,000
relationships,
um, seven different labels and 27
different relationship types.
What does this tell us? What it tells us
is obviously we got a lot of data. It's
actually not that much really. um you
know for something small um but you know
like almost a million relationships and
so really what you we're running this
just to make sure that everything is
loaded so everybody who has loaded their
data are you seeing these numbers anyone
anyone maybe maybe not no
okay this is I will take you back one
moment please hold the phone
there are three notebooks inside the
notebooks folder inside the repository.
So,
you may have to repull it.
You did. Huh?
Huh? That's not right.
Yeah. Yeah. This is not Can you reload
this because it was updated? Yeah.
That's so weird. having trouble getting
the connection for Japan
V file. It's easier to just copy the
values into the cell where it's loading
from. Yeah, you can do that, too. Yeah,
that's my advice. Yep, that's actually
really good advice. Um,
the dump file. I'm not able to download.
Uh, I'm uploading it to the Slack
channel right now. Thank you. What's
your name? Caleb. Caleb to the rescue.
Thank you, Caleb. Everybody, round of
applause. Round of applause. You're that
helpful guy at work, aren't you? You're
like, "Oh, I can just do this thing.
It'll make it easy for everybody." Thank
you, Caleb. Nia is also Nia. Also, Nia,
round of applause. We love Nia. You
probably see if you're from San
Francisco, Nia is all places, as is
Alexi. They're around all the time. So,
hopefully they're familiar faces for you
all. Um, so yeah. So, the first one is
just really meant to get you to connect
to the graph and make sure that your
connection is working. Um and just
showing you how you can get some basic
summary statistics.
Um you know, one of the things that we
can do is we can preview some of these
documents. Um so again, this is our data
model just to get you familiar with what
we're looking at. And then let's move on
to our
notebook number two is where things get
get more exciting. Um, in notebook
number two, what we what we're looking
to do is we're looking to actually start
leveraging these algorithms for where am
I?
Okay. So, when we talk about graphs like
ultimately what we're trying to do is
we're trying to help you do these things
at scale. We're trying to help you be
successful in production. We're trying
to help you get the best possible
outcome from the applications that
you're building. And the way that I that
I suggest is my little moniker which is
connect cluster curate. To your point of
how do we actually manage this at scale?
What does that look like? What do we do?
Um what we have in these notebooks walks
you through this very this process. The
way that it works is we start out by
running KN&N on similarity. So we take
the embedding for each of those
documents and we create uh we leverage a
similarity score. So um basically we
take a K of 25 we run KN&N and we
understand we start making connections
among very similar documents right
you'll see why we do that in a minute
but what this does is it sets us up for
the next step which is community
detection also known as clustering. Um,
and what it allows you to do is it
allows you to group these like items so
that you can manage them together,
right? It's very hard to look at any one
and know what's happening, but we can
certainly look at all of the things. And
then finally, what it leads us to is we
curate the grounding data set via these
techniques that work at scale. So this
is a similarity graph of context
documents um, you know, connected to
their source URLs, right? So, it makes
sense that there's a lot of overlap and
similarity because they're coming from
the same source. And you may be saying,
well, if they're all the same, like, why
do I need to know that they're similar?
How does that help me? Well, it helps
you in a few different ways. Uh, what
this thing is going crazy. Um, what I
first want to talk about is I want to
talk talk a little bit about the math
and the understanding of how community
detection works, right? Um, I promise
you there's no calculus and there's no
quiz. Um, but when
so like if we're looking at this doc,
you know, we're looking at a few
different friends, a couple of friend
groups, like it's pretty clear like
there's one click, there's another
click. It's pretty obvious, right? Like
that seems reasonable.
And then when we start getting bigger,
like these are these are similar. And
what we're seeing here, this is actually
these are actually sized by page rank,
which is an important score. Um, and
they're still like it still seems pretty
obvious, like yeah, they're clustering
together. Like it's still pretty
logical. Like I get it. Um but anybody
who has worked with graph knows that it
never looks like this. Has anybody ever
actually seen anything that looks this
tidy? No. Never. Because it looks like
this. Right? This is what we're actually
looking at. Right? In this case, what
we've got is we've got all these
different nodes. They're sized by page
rank and then the edges are weight.
They're weighted edges. Right? It's very
like the hairball people call it. um the
bowl of spaghetti, whatever it is. And
so like it's very complex. So how do we
actually find things that work? How do
we actually run comm
Oh my god, it's so sensitive. My
goodness. Um this is the boring math
part, but just so that you understand
like what is happening under the hood.
So when you're doing clustering in
graph, it's based on something called
modularity optimization. And a community
is high modularity, right? It's modular.
Makes sense, right? When the items
within or the connections within it are
highly interconnected with each other
and have a very low connection to things
outside, right? That's like the basics
of the math. So, what it's going to do
is the algorithm is going to go through
and it's going to say, okay, for every
node, is the modularity score going to
go up or is it going to go down if I put
the same label as my neighbor? Right?
So, does it belong with this group or
does it belong with that group? What
does it do to the actual numbers? Right?
Louvane is a particular type of
algorithm and this is where it says it
oh yeah it's exactly what we just talked
about. So how does it actually work? So
what it will do is it will start by
giving a single node a label and then it
does the calculation. and it says,
"Okay, like let me figure out does it go
up or does it go down and then it will
do the first pass and it'll say, okay,
these are these are the ones that are
most like most connected to each other."
And then it'll say, "Okay, well, let me
group and aggregate those and let me
look at how many what you see in step
two is you see the number of connections
between each of those clusters, right?
So, when we look at it, so you know,
it's pretty straightforward. the pinks
and the yellows. There's three edges
between them, but there's 14 within just
pink and there's two within yellow and
four within green and 14 within blue,
right? So, what it shows you is it's
showing you that like there's a lot
connected within and not so many on the
outside, right? Pretty straightforward.
That's pretty easy math, right? Um and
then it just keeps going through and
then eventually it goes down. One of the
things to know, um there is another
algorithm called Leiden. it is similar
but it um but if you need to work with
unconnected graphs so depending on
whether your graph is completely
connected or not there are different
ones but ultimately what it's doing is
it's saying you know are are these thing
which of these things is not like the
other right so label propagation is a is
another way of doing clustering and what
label propagation does is it says okay
I'm going to assign a random label to
something or I I know these labels and
then I'm going to go to the neighbors
and I'm going going to say I'm going to
assign what this one is to its neighbors
and then eventually we have these
iterations where they converge label
propagation algorithm. Now the nice
thing about the label propagation
algorithm is it's actually one of the
fastest clustering algorithms. So
especially if you've got lots and lots
of values and you want to run something
very big, it's a very fast way to do it.
Um if you need something that's like
highly nuanced, it's worth spending the
time and the computation to use one of
the other algorithms. But what I wanted
to do is I just wanted to to show you
what this looks like because label
propagation it's and modularity does the
same thing. It's really looking for
density. It's looking for density in
those graphs. So when we think about you
know this the craziness that we see here
like even in this like you can see like
little pockets of density right we see
these pockets of density. I always like
to take the soft eye when we look at
graphs. Um, and so that's what that's
what's happening with the math under the
hood, right? So what does this actually
mean in our in our code? So what we've
got is let me close this out.
So what we're going to do is the first
thing you do is you're going to run the
KN&N. So you run the KN&N on similarity.
Obviously we connect as always. Um,
there's a weird little thing you have to
do. You have to create an empty
relationship, but don't worry about
that. like I gave it to you. Um, but
that's a little little pe what it's
probably because we don't need that. Um,
but then we run the query and I just
want to walk through how the query is
actually built and what it looks like.
So, the first thing that we have is do I
have my I want I want to see this.
Sorry, somebody's got a question over
here. Yes. Then then over there, Caleb.
There we go. Here we go. Did you have a
question? Yes. Yeah,
[Music]
graph.pro.
So, just to go over like what what what
the process is when you're when you're
actually um running the algorithms. The
first thing you need to do is you need
to project a graph because most of the
time when you're running the algorithm,
you're not running it on the entire
graph, right? We're running it on
something small. So in our case we want
to run k nearest neighbors just on the
documents right. So what we need to do
is we create this uh this projection. So
here we've got we're calling the
projection we're calling it doc. So the
first thing you'll see is the name of
the projection which is docs. What then
what we look at is we look at which
nodes the next thing you're going to see
is nodes. So for us we're using
documents right? So we want documents. I
want to include the property embedding.
So, you really want to make sure you're
only bringing in what you need, right?
Because it's just going to make things
run faster. Um, and then because it's
just the documents aren't related to
each other yet, right? We know that from
the data model, those documents are
related to the responses, but they're
not related to each other. We're
building this similarity among them. And
so, it it happens to be an empty
relationship. And then what it will do
is it will give us the graph name, the
node count, and it'll it'll let us know
that it ran. And what that ends up
looking like is, let me go to my aura.
Where is my aura?
I'm so not Aura, as the middle school
would say right now. Okay. Um, so let's
go into explore. Anybody here have
middle schoolers or like know the whole
like brain rot like RZ aura ski like
it's insanity. All right. Um, so what
we're going to be looking at is when we
look at documents,
I've run it already. Um, so we're going
to see that there's similarity among
them, but right now we're going to see
these documents. And what I want to look
at is Oh, yeah. So, I'm going to look at
documents that are connected
to
[Music]
come on
similar
to documents.
Oh, actually, let me Yeah, that'll work.
It takes a second to run. Um, one of the
one of the things that um I did is I
actually changed what the way that we
look at it in the graph. Just so that
you know, I changed it so that it's
actually the colors of the nodes are by
community because what I wanted to see
is I wanted to see like do we start to
see let me run this one more time. Let
me clear the scene.
do this.
Oh, dear sweet Wi-Fi.
Maybe I should open up my Neo4j like
desktop. Um, yeah. So, what we're going
to see is we're going to see the
connections in and among the
Hold on a second. I don't like this. I
don't like this at all.
What it's eventually going to show you
is it's going to show you the
similarities in and among and it's going
to be like the greatest ever hairball.
So, in this particular case, like this
is what it might look like. Um, and what
we see is like we saw with the big one,
like you're going to see like clusters
of documents that are very similar.
The other thing that we're going to see
is we're going to see what I call the
bridge documents, the ones that will
often be the the middleman. we call it
um betweenness centrality and so but you
want to understand like I said it's the
soft eye you want to understand what is
the clustering of your documents and
again you might be asking yourself like
why is that helpful and I promise you
the reason that it's helpful is because
what we end up being able to do is
understand what's happening within the
data so this is a 2D version of of these
embeddings and these clusters and what
we see is we see you know it looks like
a bowl of Froot Loops like how again
Allison how is this helpful I'm not a
data scientist like what is happening
here um but when we zoom in we see a
couple of things in one case we have a
single community document cluster so
what we're seeing is there's a lot of
similarity in the embedding right
they're all in that same community
they're all very similar and then in
this other side we've got some they're
kind of spread out like nothing really
clear on a perimeter right like you're
like is that good clustering or hot. Um,
and so my question to you is which is
better?
Which of these do you think might say,
"Oh, yeah, like we've got it. We've got
what we need. We're good." Pros and
cons. Somebody says some single. Single
community. What's the What's the thought
on a single community?
Yeah, they're very similar. That's
awesome. And in traditional clustering
that would be great, right? If we're
talking about clustering customers,
we're doing customer 360, we're like,
oh, this is a group, this is a thing.
But one of the things that we have
though is that means we have a lot of
very similar documents.
So the question is, do we really want it
to look like that? Customers, yes.
Documents, no. Right? Because one of the
things that we need to understand is we
need to really be efficient. So when we
talk about what is a high quality
grounding data set in your retrieval
augmented generation, these are our five
basic principles that we that we go by.
Is it relevant? Is it actually giving an
augmenting answer? Is it reliable?
Right? Like do you have do do you have
like a lot of variety that's coming back
on something like is it really disparit
from these communities because there's a
hole in your data because that we don't
know, right? There's a gap in all this
highdimensional space. there's this like
big blind spot that you don't know
about. And again, is it efficient? How
many people here are really worried
about their applications being
efficient? Everybody. I know, right? It
makes you crazy. So again, how do we do
this at scale? What does that look like?
So once we've done this clustering and
we've assigned these communities to
these nodes, then we can start looking
at the data itself. Right? In this
particular instance, one of the first
things we did, and you'll you'll see it,
I left all the the dump that you have
has all the errors in it. So you can
play with them. Um, we can see that the
median average word length is 512
characters. Well, our chunks are a
length of 512. So that's probably not
good data for us, right? That's not
helpful. Um, and it's clearly very
different from everybody else. So what
does that look like? Median word count
one. So all of these are summary
statistics at that at that cluster
level, at that community level. And so
when we looked into it, we found this is
very, you know, like again, we brought
our data in from, you know, web pages
and all these different places. So
clearly this is not going to be helpful
to an answer, right? At least not to a
human, right? So this is a way that we
can start to clean something out. The
basics, right? Like just the basics.
The other thing that's going to come up
and that high density, like that high
similarity we saw is this highly similar
text chunks. In this particular one
here, community 4702,
our average similarity is 0.98. We have
49 documents, 49 chunks that are almost
completely identical. If you're doing a
retriever that gives, you know, the top
10, that's not going to give you any
context at all. It's just going to be
really confident about this one thing,
right? How do you know that it's even
the right thing? Right? So, one of the
things that you want to start looking at
is ways that you can sometimes increase
the diversity, right? Like I have a I
have a a talk that I've submitted many
many times that has never been accepted
and it's called the dark side of
distance metrics. How cosine similarity
broke America. Right? I don't know why
it doesn't get accepted. Why is that?
Right? Because cosine similarity gives
you exactly what you want.
Gives you exactly what you want. Right?
Like I call it the chicken nuggets and
twinkies. If I had a robot in my house
and I went to San Francisco and it was
responsible for cooking for my kids,
when I came back, all I'd be making is
chicken nuggets and twinkies, right?
That's the same thing that's happening
in our algorithms. And so where this
becomes really, really important.
We're everybody here is working with
agents.
You are refining signal at every turn.
So, if you get a signal, it's going to
pick up on it and it's going to run with
it and it's going to go down to the next
agent and the next agent and the next
agent and whatever that whatever that
path that it got on, it's going to go
right because that's what we programmed
it to do. It's doing its job. It's doing
exactly what we told it to do. But is
that what we want it to do? So one of
the ways that like this community
approach to documentation is really
interesting is you can look at what are
the variety of documents. You can
actually use reranking for diversity in
your responses. So let's say we do a
vector retriever, right? We take the
vector retriever and it comes back with
this scoring. These things are all
really similar. Okay. Well, most of them
are from this com this community, but
then the ones a little further down are
from another community. So you can
actually do different ways of reranking.
So you can wait for divers. You can wait
for diversity. You can wait for page
rank, right? Like one of the examples we
have in here is using page rank of these
vectors. Which ones are the most
important? Which are the ones that
people go to the most? We want to be
feeding that back, right? It's like it's
why Google made billions of dollars,
right? Page rank changed the way
everybody searched. So what I want you
to be thinking about is you need to be
thinking about what I call intelligent
outcome management. It's not just about
like you know AI, artificial
intelligence, but what are the outcomes
that we're getting and how do we give
really good ones? And I'm here to show
you how you can use these algorithms to
help you like diversify that a little
bit.
So when we looked at these highly
similar text chunks, they're highly
similar. It's because it comes from our
documentation, right? We've got multiple
versions, right? Like we've got a
version for 1.5 and a version for 1.6.
Well, the algorithm doesn't change,
right? The algorithm doesn't change. So
that's why we have all these repeats. So
the other great thing about graphs
because you know every chance I get to
love on a graph, I will um is you
actually can very easily in this one
moment apoch nodes collapse.
Awesome procedures on cipher. So what
it's going to do is it's going to do two
things. one is going to make your
retrieval much more efficient because
you now have one version of it instead
of many. But what it's also going to do
is it's going to maintain the lineage.
It's going to maintain the connections.
So now we've got a single document but
we can see all of those sources. We can
see where it came from. So you don't
lose the institutional understanding,
right? Nobody likes And who likes
dropping rows? Everybody gets worried
when you drop a row, right? Like maybe
it's just me. I always get worried like
I'm dropping rows. Is this what I want?
So in this case, you don't have to. And
that's what's so great and flexible
about the graph is that you can do these
largecale management moments and you're
you get more efficient. You get really
clear. You don't or you're not over
bundling something or overpowering
something. Question. What does it mean
to collapse here? Oh, so basically what
we're doing here is we're saying these
four are all the basically all the same.
The text and the embedding are the same.
So we're going to collapse them into a
single node and we're going to maintain
the original relationships. So in this
case when then when you hit that
embedding you're only hitting it once
instead of 19 or 49 times in our case.
Yes. So on documents that are pretty
much very similar. Yeah. They have
various properties slightly different
when you do the collapses join all the
properties together. It depends on how
you want to do it. Like you certainly
could. I mean it may be that you don't
you may only want to like adjust what's
in the index, right? like it could be a
different way that you want to manage it
like depending on what you need to
maintain, right? If it's legal then you
probably don't want to lose anything.
Um, you know, there's there's options.
Yeah.
There's a microphone for you because
it's a good question. Everybody needs to
hear it. So, the documents will be
exactly the same for each one of the
pages. the chunking was similar and the
similar kind of things got picked up. So
will does chunking impact when in these
kinds of mechanisms how the
similarities? Yeah, I mean because it it
could be right because if it's the same
page but one has like an extra paragraph
for that version then the chunking might
split differently. Right? So you're not
going to it's not going to it's not like
a magic wand, right? It's no magic
eraser, but it's definitely an easy way
to increase your efficiency and increase
the quality of the output in the data
itself.
Yes. So you did the clustering on
documents or did you do the clustering
on all different kinds of nodes that you
have? I did the clustering just on the
document nodes which in this case are
actually chunks right so it's just on
those. So it takes the embedding right
for that chunk and then we run that kn
so that we understand like do we have
these really high density places. The
other thing it allows you to do is
understand like do I have the right
information? Right? So um where are we?
Right? So again like what are the most
frequently used communities? We've seen
this already. Right? This is a
conversation. You know these are the
original documents. This is the the next
set some of it right. Um, like I've been
doing more research into understanding
like how people travel around the
communities in different conversations.
Do they do they all end in one place or
do they start in one place or how long
does it take someone to get to the right
area? Right? I mean, it's, you know,
we're we're basically tracking human
cognition by watching the way people
move around their thought process,
right?
um you know this is like one particular
visualization of a single conversation
and for each of these we've got you know
10 pieces that 10 context documents that
come back you know we have a K of 10 and
so it looked at which communities are
they coming from across this
conversation so this person originally
was starting out in this area and then
clearly ended up over here and then when
they got to whatever community group
number whatever it is um they got to
their answer and then they moved
So whether your conversations are short
or long is going to depend what route
you want people to take right I think
about um you know I always go to product
analytics right so what is it that they
someone might need to know so so much
becomes available and you know again on
the developer side like maybe these
things are important to us maybe they're
not but as someone who's building agents
it has to be important to you right we
have to really take accountability
for the signals that we're amplifying in
our systems and be aware. It's why the
data scientists and the developers
aren't on the other are on different
sides anymore. We're all AI engineers.
Question someone. No. Okay. All right.
My soap box. Thank you. I appreciate
that. Um document usage. We talked about
this. We talked about all these things.
I don't think there's Yeah, I think
we're good. Yeah. Oh, this is just
another uh you know the betweenness
centrality, right? like um to understand
why why it might be important. Um again,
if you think about what is it that we're
delivering, you know, like somebody said
like who's the most important person at
the company? Is it the person that's
connected to any everybody or is it, you
know, the one person that talks to both
sides of the of the business, right?
Between the centrality says it's this
person. Page rank says it's somebody
else. So that's the other thing too is
when we're trying to figure out what's
important, we have a variety of
algorithms that do different things that
make that available to you. You know,
conversation lengths, right? I mean,
this is just some of the basics. Um, but
this is just another really interesting
one is we're looking at um good ratings
and bad, right?
Right. So this is just an analysis based
on the community, right? How many are in
the community? Um, and then are the
ratings good or bad by community? Right?
If you find that there's a that there's
a cluster of documents where the ratings
are significantly worse than the others,
let me go look at that. Let me go look
at those documents. Maybe it's, you
know, outdated. I had somebody, this is
my interesting story. So, um I do some
work with some folks who do like DoD and
Fed work and um former Navy Seal and
he's just like, "Yeah, I couldn't
believe it." And I'm like, "What?" He's
like, "They," somebody was doing this
proposal and they have like this one
thing that they have to put in like some
risk assessment thing and like it's just
like they copy and paste it over and
over and over again. And so one day he
got really curious and he wanted to
actually track where it came from. It
was almost word for word something from
the Vietnam War that people are still
putting into these documents,
right? Like it's got like if we just
threw it into a rag application, it
would have really high page rank.
Everybody's using it. But where did it
come from? Is that what we want? So
looking at the things that are
influential, not because they're an
anomaly, but because we're amplifying
that signal, is that the signal we want
to amplify? That's a whole other like AI
observability thing. But the reason I
bring it up is that our job is to build
good smart applications. We are
responsible for the outcomes of these
processes. And these are some ways that
you can take a new approach to what
you're doing. Right?
Let me go back. Questions, comments,
concerns.
Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. Um I don't know that there's
I mean you have to do the projection and
run the run the algorithm. Um but we've
got it in here. Community detection and
assignment.
I believe between us is in here. Oh,
between us might be in number three.
Creating secondary relationship. We're
not even going to get to that. Yeah. So
there's a between the centrality. Um, so
when you when you look at the
algorithms, it's they're all going to be
pretty much the same. It's going to be
GDS and then the name of the algorithm.
And then there's a couple of different
options. Stream means run the
calculations and let me look at them.
Just put them here. Mutate will actually
change the the projection. You can also
write. So if you do the algorithm.right,
it's going to write back to the node and
will write that assignment back. So
sometimes you just want to play, you
just want to look at it, right?
Sometimes you may want to just change it
within the production and just play
around. So you've got a few different
ways that you can apply the algorithm
once those numbers come out. Um and the
basic is you're always going to do a
call. You're going to call the algorithm
and then the first thing you're going to
do is say which projection am I running
this on? Right? In this projection um I
actually had um like a I I created a new
a new relationship called co-occurrence.
Where is it? Yeah. So, what this did is
it says, okay, I'm going to look at the
message and I want to see the different
documents for that that are in the same
message. And for each of those where the
elements aren't the same, right? So, I
don't want to create a connection to
itself. I want to merge. Merge is um you
can either create or merge a a
relationship. Um merge just means if it
doesn't exist, make it. um going I'm
going to merge the chunk one or the
context one with context two and I'm
going to create this new relationship
co- occurs with and the reason I wanted
to do this is I wanted to see like which
things come up together a lot because
sometimes it's not just about the
similarity if I've done a really good
job of curating my data set and I don't
have a lot of that redundancy I want to
see like what are the concepts that are
coming together like what are the things
that come together from there you can
then look at the way they travel around
each piece from one to another. So what
I did is I created this co-occurrence,
right? So yes, so like if we went back
to our um
um so basically co-occurrence just says
all of these documents that were pulled
in by this question will now have a
relationship among them, right? And then
we wait that by how often do they come
up together, right? Um you can do the
same thing with traversal. So these
chunks come first, these chunks come
second. So if you know that the
conversations usually go in that
direction, do you want to figure what's
the probability? Can I predict the next
thing? Can I figure out where the
conversation is going to go? So all of
this to say that, you know, I love that
there's a graph rag track. I love that
it's just sort of like the way many
people are doing things. And what I want
you to know is you've done all the hard
work of building the graph. Now let's
use it even more. Let's get even more
out of it. There was a question
somewhere. Yeah. Yeah. Co-occurrences
when like the um
you ask a question and then the the
retrieved answer like you you have like
two answers that are commonly retrieved
together like to that question. Is that
co occurrence? Am I understanding it
correctly? The co-occurrence is
all everything that came in to this one.
Like if you're doing a K of 10, all of
those 10 will co-occur. Meaning like
they all were answered together. Okay?
They all were fed back at the same time,
right? So it's it's almost like an
affinity of like these things often come
together. Then you can, like I said, you
can do the same thing. You can expand it
out into like follow on like these
things usually follow those things,
right? So we can start to see and that's
where, you know, things get juicy.
My nerdy like data science brain gets
super excited. I'm like, "Oh my god,
then we can check this. Then we can
check that and maybe somebody cares."
Yeah.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. I'll be back. I
got a question more more not a technical
question, more general. So, you
mentioned uh DoD and Fed space. So, we
operate in the DoD space. Oh, nice. More
on the industry side. Yeah. So what is
the you know what are your thoughts on
the adoption of these technologies
within the within the do both on the
government side and also on the system.
I have I have a lot of opinions on that.
Nia will tell you um I think when it the
the most interesting conversations that
I have are around accountability and
traceability.
There was I was talking to someone
literally this weekend and said there
was an unnamed person who's currently
running for Congress and they said about
the military, "Oh, they're just going to
need to learn to trust the AI."
I've never been so alarmed in my life. I
was just like, "No, no, trust but
verify. Trust but verify, please."
Right? I mean, like, as someone who's
been a data scientist for a long time,
like we do our best, but there are
unintended consequences. Like, we didn't
know we were building an echo chamber.
We just thought we were giving you
chicken nuggets and Twinkies, right?
Like we didn't know it was going to
break America, but we did it, right?
Like I was one of those people like I
built those algorithms. Hello. Thank
you. Um, you know, and so like I think
the best thing that we can all do is to
just keep those things in mind. And so
that's where the conversations like my
conversations with them like and I'm not
like saying like, "Oh, you're so dumb.
Like you don't know." Like people don't
know, right? Like like I've been doing
this for years. Like I've lived in the
calculus, right? Like I've lived in like
you know understanding the mathematics
of the neural network, right? Like I've
spent a lot of time like the data
scientists we had rigor and we had
mathematics and we like had every time
we released a model we had model reports
and all this stuff
and now it's just like
just trust it. It's good. We're fine,
right? Um and a lot of it is right. Like
we do I mean it's the world we live in.
Like I'm certainly not like I'm not a
naysayer. Like I love AI. I love what's
possible. Um but I just think that we
just need to be a little bit thoughtful
about what we're doing and like that's
why these are easy things to do, right?
Like and like once you're aware of it,
you're like, "Oh yeah, I'm going to get
a much better answer. That's awesome.
Let's do that." Yes. I have a question
on the more the knowledge graph side of
things. Yeah. Is there like an easier
way to is there an easier way to
automatically create the knowledge graph
because u you know things like
graphletits
have really made things a lot easier for
a lot of people. Yeah. Um versus like
this is to me it's kind of like old
school way of creating graph which is
you really got to be the domain expert
and know all the ontologies and all the
relationships. But what if you wanted to
do that automatically many times over
for different types of businesses? Yeah,
how do you do that? Yeah, there it's a
really excellent question and so
hopefully everybody heard the question
is like how how do you like build graphs
at scale, right? Like how do you do it
without having to be an expert? Um the
the knowledge graph builder, the KG
builder that Neo4j build because these
are these are questions that people
have, right? Um there's some really
interesting ways like you can actually
use the simple KG pipeline and just
throw your documents in and just say
tell me what's important right it's
going to go through and do basic named
entity recognition based on those
entities it'll do another pass and say
how are they related and what it'll do
is it'll look at each document
individually but then what you start to
see is you start to see like the natural
organic like what's actually in there
what comes up um so I love that for
experimentation and for understanding
because oftentimes as builders We don't
know. We're not the subject matter
experts, but we're responsible for
building the architecture for them to
get the right answer, right? So, how
what tools do we have to try and service
it? Because then you can run it and
it'll be noisy like it will look like
spaghetti. It will be noisy. But then
you can say, okay, tell me how many of
this label, how many of that label, show
me like what is this, what is the page
rank, what is the between the
centrality, right? you can run these
kinds of algorithms to understand and
then from there you say oh okay
according to this set of documents this
is the ontology that has risen out of
it. So you can take a very organic
approach. Um, sometimes people will go
in with a very specific data model in
mind. And even in those cases, I always
encourage people to run run the KG
builder for experimentation purposes
because it could be that there's
something in your documents that you
didn't even know was valuable, right?
Like let them speak like let them like
let the ontology rise. Yeah. Um,
question is like I think today our
industry has been writing content more
for consumption by humans. Now this is
changing toward consumption by agents.
Yeah. Do you see this playing the graph
analytics and what you're showcasing is
playing for persona for content writers
and whether for completeness how are
they writing and producing more content
is helping them is that the primary
persona we are targeting I mean I listen
it can go in any direction right like
one of the things that I'm really
excited about is um the concept of like
I call it um it's not about human in the
loop it's about accountability in the
loop right like like we said we're going
agent to agent to agent And so what do
we then pass to that agent? Right? So if
we have some of this information, right?
Like if we're concerned about amplifying
signal, right? And if we're concerned
about, you know, like a series of agents
going in the wrong direction, right? You
think of a ship. If it's off by one
degree now, it's fine. You know, 100
miles later, not so fine. Um, so how do
we how do we keep steering the ship when
it's autonomous? And so that's some of
the interesting things, too. Like when
we look at this memory graph right we
can say like like this application graph
we can say okay I'm going to pass this
to the agent and I'll pass uh like this
context or this particular information
about what came before or you know like
you can look at like um sort of like the
velocity of how quickly it's going from
one community to another right like
there's so many interesting ways you can
do the math to look at it um but yeah
like I think like really understanding
like how do we drive our agents. How do
we drive our agents in chains is super
sexy, super exciting for me. Yeah.
Question about content hygiene. Yes. So
a lot of times we realize that um it's
garbage in garbage out. Yeah. And uh we
ourselves sometimes aren't aware of like
some issues with our own content whether
one part is contradicting another. Yeah.
Or something's just inaccurate.
Is there any fancy math with graphs that
can help us identify potential issues
with content hygiene? I mean, I would I
would want to give you a more thoughtful
answer than something off the top of my
head. Like, I don't want to I don't want
to throw something out that's just kind
of like, oh, what is this? Um, yes. Is
it going to solve everything? No. But
again, some of it has to do with what is
it connected to, right? So if we think
of um you know how fraud detection works
right like like or so I worked on the
Syra they did election graph for with
Syracuse University last year for the
presidential election and they were
tracking advertising like across
Facebook and Instagram and and I Jenny
who ran the program she said something
really interesting to me which is if you
want to know how someone's going to vote
it's actually not their friends but if
you look at the friends of friends that
second hop out is actually more
predictive of how someone's going to
vote than their immediate group, which I
just thought was fascinating, right?
Like why is that a thing? But it's the
same kind of thing that might be
possible, right? So let's look at what
is it connected to. Are we finding that
there's like some sort of like density
of something like in that area
potentially. Um the other thing about me
is I love to be available. I love to
chat as you can see. So, uh, feel free
to connect with me on LinkedIn and DM me
and if you ever want to noodle, like I'm
always happy to noodle on like all the
things because my hope is that you leave
here today and you start thinking about
like what might be interesting to you,
what could you look at a little bit
differently. Um,
yeah, another question. Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, thank you Allison. It's a great
session really. Um, I wanted to ask um
about the
embeddings versus the structure. Yeah.
And yes, it's a it's a research
question. There's a lot of approaches
out there and of course it depends upon
depends upon the domain. Mhm. But I
wanted to ask you if you or the team has
any specific experiences in terms of how
to leverage the embedding per note let's
say. Yeah. Versus the structure of the
graph. Because for example in the
morning session we've seen just simple
aggregation of the two. Yeah. close the
eyes the eyes and let's see how we can
you spoke to a little bit about the
ranking. So my question is how would you
start approaching a given specific
domain where we have embedding in the
same embedding space for every node?
Yeah. Plus the structure. Yeah. Um there
are actually really interesting ways
that you can do combinations of uh not
just the text embedding but the
embedding of the node itself. Right. So
so for those of you who don't know the
concept that we have of this text
embedding you can also do on the node.
And so it's an embedding really of the
structure of any given node and which
relationships it's connected to. Um so
yeah there's some really interesting
things that you can do there. Um one of
the things that we like didn't get to
today but is like you know leveraging
page rank and you know vector to like
rerank. So there's definitely some
interesting things that you can do. I
don't know if we have content on that
specifically. Um but definitely reach
out to me and I will reach out to our
people and we'll get you a really good
answer on that. For sure. Yes. Thank
you.
We're coming up on time.
I still don't understand the community
detection a little bit. Yeah. So like
how does it work? What is happening? All
right.
So
we got a few different ways that we can
look at it. This is one example how how
Lou actually works. So like I said, what
it'll start to do is it'll it'll assign
it'll assign a label and then what it
says is okay, let me look at its
neighbors and if I give the neighbors
the same label, does that modularity
does that interconnectedness number get
better or worse, right? So different
different clustering algorithms are
going to do things different ways,
right? Um, but in this case, this is
what we're looking at is like, and if
you think about it, it's like, you know
how you have some friends and you all
know each other. You're all really
tight, but then you have this other
friend who's got like all these
different like friend groups that
they're a part of. They don't have like
their one little niche. It's kind of
like that. So, the more interconnected
it is, the more relationships they have
among each other. That's what it's
looking for in the math.
like cipher query right like how would
this be of any use in terms of like
getting the actual data from the query?
Yeah. So when we talk about the
community detection the community
detection is really meant to be like a
production helper. It's going to allow
you to curate at scale. It's going to
allow you to understand at scale like
where things are moving. um the the
community itself may not necessarily be
part of your answer unless, as I
mentioned, you want more diversity in an
answer. You want to cover a larger
domain than just what's really close to
the vector, right? So, think of um if
I'm, you know, I don't know, I'm in
sales at Amazon, like I don't want to,
you just bought luggage. I'm not going
to show you more luggage, right? I want
to show you the things that are often
bought with, right? the connected
pieces, right? It's sort of like that.
So, in that case, it could be helpful.
Um, but from a content perspective, it's
like, do I want to give you just what
you have or is there some benefit to
spreading the net a little wider in
what's being brought back by that vector
retriever.
Okay. So, instead of just getting that
one embedding, it gets like all the
surrounding embeddings as well. Yeah.
So, depending on how you build your
retrievers, right, depending on what
your thresholds are, depending on, you
know, lots and lots of different ways to
do it. Um, but I again I'm happy to
noodle with anyone any time. I literally
get paid to help people build things. So
I love my job. Like help me keep doing
my job by asking me lots of questions
and letting me help you. And one last
question. Yeah. So like when it detects
what's a community, does it only like
check its surrounding nodes or even like
nodes across the entire graph? You know,
I'll why don't you and I we can talk
about more community after because I
don't want to keep everybody because I
know we're getting close to time, but
it's a good question. So thank you for
that. Um, what I do want to say is if
you've been with us this morning and
this afternoon, your day with Neo4j is
not over because our lovely friend Alexi
is here. Um, and he's hosting our AI
agent meetup this evening. There we go.
Everybody say hi to Alexi. If you don't
know him, you should. Like, he's just
one of the most like vivacious and
passionate people about tech I've ever
met in my life. Um, so yeah, please join
us for the agent protocols tonight on
graphs and MCP. feel free to reach out
to me on LinkedIn. And I just want to
thank you all for your attention. I know
that it was a it was a lot, but please
like just be curious. Be curious.
That's it. Thank you, Alison. Thank you.
[Music]